well
our usual babysitter Talia who was like
a high school student and I adored her
so much uh my mum maybe she had exams or
something I'm not sure but my mum got
another babysitter in this old lady and
she was really grumpy and mean and I was
so pissed off that we didn't have Talia
anymore and um and in defiance I was
just not going to listen to anything
this old mean lady babysitter had to say
she was like go have your bath and I was
like No just like go take a bath and I
was like um
you are going to pay for this in my head
I said that and then I went and I took a
giant kitchen knife and ketchup and I
lay naked on the tiles outside the
bathroom covered myself and catch up and
put the knife next to me and I lay there
I like I committed I lay there for 40
minutes on these cold tiles and I
remember thinking like she has got to
come check on me soon it's very
irresponsible actually for her not to
come check soon but eventually she did
come and I almost gave her a heart
attack anyway she didn't come back she
didn't come back